in many many different cultures the
rainbow
appears as a symbol of hope beauty
love in many ways the rainbow flag might
be more important than ever
[Music]
our story begins in san francisco in the
late 1960s
young gay men lesbian women were
arriving from all over the country and
all around the world
many of them fleeing places where they
were experiencing incredible violence
and one of those men was gilbert baker
everyone was aware of gilbert he was
extremely dramatic
i think the operative word would be
flamboyant that's cleve jones
he wrote this book when we rise my life
in the movement
cleveland gilbert met as two young
activists planning the 1977 san
francisco gay pride event
back then it was called gay freedom day
we were all part of a circle
of activists who were talking about the
need for a new symbol
that would connect us all and one day
gilbert told cleve about an idea he had
come up with
he showed me the drawings he'd done and
i saw the power of it right away
and each color had special significance
one color meant love another was
honestly i think he kind of made that up
after the fact it
came to him as he said from the sky with
a team of volunteers
including cleve gilbert sewed and dyed
the flags in preparation for gay freedom
day
when those first flags went up these
enormous poles
and the wind took them and lifted them
up against the blue sky
it was really breathtaking gilbert and i
stood there and watched and we knew that
everybody that was there
was looking up at those rainbows and
knowing at that exact moment that this
now
would be our symbol to take this
beautiful symbol from nature
and say this is the symbol of these
people who were called
unnatural who were required to live in
the shadows
he really devoted his life not only to
making flags but banners
you